[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
another exciting episode of cinematic
masterpieces my name is and am and I am
your host for today we're here with
absolutely nobody but we're still going
to have a lot of fun so fasten your seat
belts and let's take a deep dive into
the fascinating Trilogy that comprises
break bat better colol and El Camino
these shows written by Vince Gilligan
really popped off when they first came
out and they're still being watched by
people to this day after more than 15
years also there are going to be
spoilers during this podcast so watch
the trilogy first and then come here so
the tale begins with Breaking Bad a
series that redefined the crime drama
genre completely uh we're catapulted
into world where the moral compass
points in every direction But True North
this epic narrative is like a painting
where every stroke is deliberate and
every shade conveys a profound story
Breaking Bad introduces us to a very
interesting character Walter White whose
transformation from a humble chemistry
teacher to a ruthless drug lord is
nothing short of a modern-day Greek
tragedy and will have you Cliff hanging
at the end of each
episode better call Sal a spin-off or a
prequel to Breaking Bad explores the
origins of the Charming yet morally
flexible lawyer Jimmy McGill later known
as Saul Goodman Vince skel's genius
shines through every episode crafting a
world that blurs the lines between right
and wrong with exquisite
finesse in better call SA we reminded of
the phrase the devil is in the details
as we follow Jimmy Miguel's
transformation into Saul Goodman it's as
if you watching an artist brush bold
Strokes on a canvas of ambition and
ethics Al Camino serves as the final
movement in the symphony this postcript
to Breaking Bad provides closure to
Jesse pinkman's difficult Journey the
show cinematography is on top tier the
camera becomes a Storyteller in itself
guiding us to the Stark Sun soaked
Landscapes of New
Mexico the central theme of this Trilogy
is the intricate dance of morality it's
a stark REM minder that the line between
right and wrong is often often blurred
in the pursuit of ambition survival or
Justice our characters Traverse this
moral tight Trope and we are compelled
to question the very nature of morality
itself as the saying goes you can't make
an omlet without breaking a few acts
each character's choices and actions
carry consequences they find themselves
in situations where the distinction
between hero and anti-hero becomes
increasingly hazy this is the heart of
the triology the con constant
negotiation between one's principles and
the demands of life's
Crucible The end justifies the means is
a central theme throughout the trilogy
Walter White Saul Goodman and Jesse
Pinkman all grapple with this moral
conundrum they justify reprehensible
actions as necessary steps towards
perceived greater good a concept that
forces us to confront the ethics of our
own
decisions this Trilogy exemplifies the
idiom you can judge a book by its cover
the characters exteriors often mask a
complexity that is only revealed through
their actions and decisions their
Journeys serve as a reminder that
Redemption and
transformation are attainable even in
the darkest of
circumstances let's explore the
character arcs in more depth in Breaking
Bad Walter White's transformation from a
Meek downtrodden teacher to the
formidable Heisenberg teaches us that a
leopart can change its spots beneath
White's seemingly benign exterior lies a
ruthless cunning individual whose
choices unveil his true nature as the
series progresses Walter's character
evolves from a sympathetic down on his
luck protagonist to a morally
compromised and ruthless drug lord his
journey is marked by his growing
involvement in the drug trade leading to
violence deception and the manipulation
of those around him Walter wise's
character embodies the notion that even
the most ordinary individuals are
capable of great darkness when driven by
desperation and the desire for
power he justifies his actions as
necessary for his family's Financial
Security often echoing the phrase I did
it for the family this moral ambiguity
is Central to the the series and
challenges viewers to question the
boundaries of right and wrong as I
mentioned
before while in Better Call Saul the
transformation of Jimmy Migel into Saul
Goodman is a gradual process emphasizing
the idea that achieving one's schools
whether Noble or nef Furious often
requires patience and persistence it's
fascinating to watch the way Jimmy goes
from being a lawyer in Elder Law and
protecting old people from Modern Day
scams in Albuquerque to defend ing
Mexican cartel members in court and
being an important asset to them while
also having to watch over his love life
with Kim waxer who is also an
attorney in Al Camino the saying action
speak louder than words takes Center
Stage the protagonist in Al Camino Jesse
Pinkman a former meth cook the partner
of one of the biggest drug lords in USA
has always had issues during the series
of Breaking bed he realized that even
after after making money he still wasn't
happy the only times he was happy were
the ones where he was with his
girlfriend Shane in Al Camino is shown
Jesse pinkman's escape from captivity
which is an action-packed high stakes
Journey it reminds us that in face of
adversity one must take both steps to
secure their freedom and
future the trilogy also underscores the
concept of what goes around comes around
characters actions and decisions often
have unforeseen consequences serving as
a stark reminder that life has a way of
holding us accountable for our own
choices no matter how well hidden they
may be some characters even though they
aren protagonist just have to be manches
because of their importance one of them
is Gus Fring who is a Chilean American
drug lord and owner of Los hermano
restaurant chain in Breaking bed behind
his legitimate front go is a ruthless
calculated criminal mastermind who
partners with Walter White and Jesse
pingman in the drug trade his
professionalism and coldblooded approach
to eliminating threats make him a
central and memorable character well
personally my favorite character of the
series was ignatio Nao Varga he is a
calculating intelligent career criminal
he is the right-and man to Tuka salanka
here to the crime family of the same
name while not yet a Kingpin himself
nacho is bright and has the ear of his
terrifying boss nacho hires Jimmy as his
La after being introduced to him by
tokko he secretly begins working with
Mike Erman trout at the end of season 1
he admire Mike's calm and calculated way
of working compared to too's impulsive
and insane way of
working now let's talk about Mike Erman
trout who is a stoic and skilled
enforcer in Breaking bat with a
background found in law enforcement he
serves as the head of security for Gus
Frank's drug
Empire Mike is known for his unwavering
professionalism and a strict moral code
which sets him apart from other
characters in the series his complex
relationships with Walter White and
Jesse Pinkman and his tragic end make
him a fan favorite and enigmatic figure
unlike Walter everything might did he
did for his
family in summary Breaking Bad better
colol and Al Camino have edged their
names in the anals of cinematic history
they are a testament to the power of
Storytelling character development and
the Art of creating a moral maze where
characters navigate their own
Destinies so this was it for today thank
you for joining us on cinematic
masterpieces until next time too
remember that in the world of Vince
Gilligan's Creation The end justifies
the means and we're left yearning for
more stay tuned tuned stay cinematic
stay curious goodbye and have a
wonderful day or night it doesn't
[Music]
matter